This graph that we just came up with, is different from other exponential
functions we've seen. Because it isn't growing. It's decreasing everywhere
instead of increasing. We call this exponential decay instead of exponential
growth. We can see that the graph of an exponential decay function looks like
the opposite of an exponential growth function. It's going down instead of
going up, as you move from left to right across the graph. Now decay might
sound like a funny word for this sort of behavior, but it's called this because
of some of the context in which functions like this pop up in nature. We would
use exponential decay equations to describe a panda population going extinct, a
giant group of bacteria dying off. Or the amount of medicine in the bloodstream
decreasing. Instead of having a growth rate like we have in functions like this
one. We have a decay rate. Thinking back to our original form of an expotential
function f of x equals a to the x. What do you think that a needs to equal in
order for a graph to show decay instead of growth? What interval should a lie
in?